émission spéciale sur rt france dans
quelques minutes emmanuel macron
s'adresse aux français deux semaines
après le début du couvre-feu dans les
métropoles françaises les plus touchées
de nouvelles restrictions sont attendus
pour tenter de reprendre le contrôle de
l'épidémie le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations bat des records est la
situation est très tendue dans les
hôpitaux
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est presque 20 heures
bienvenue sur rt france pour cette
édition spéciale
le pays s'apprête il à vivre un nouveau
confinement généralisée nous allons être
fixée dans quelques instants avec la
prise de parole du président de la
république
mais avant nous allons rejoindre notre
reporter katia pique les devants
l'elysée katia bonsoir alors nous sommes
donc un dans l'attenté de nouvelles
mesures elles ont été discutées ce matin
lors d'un nouveau conseil de défense
avant le conseil des ministres
[Musique]
oui absolument l'heure l'hypothèse à
d'un recompte finement semble se
profiler un cela reste au conditionnel
mais les premières informations qui
filtraient bien ce serait celle d'un re
confinement à partir de jeudi à minuit
alors même si donc tout ça reste au
conditionnel je vais vous parler de
quelques mesures comme par exemple un
télé travail qui serait systématiser
mais certains secteurs continuera à
fonctionner comme le btp le secteur
agricole mais aussi c'est une nouveauté
l'administration les services publics
ainsi les écoles resteraient ouvertes
jusqu'au lycée seules les universités
fermerait mais seuls les commerces de
première nécessité pourront ouvrir ce
qui signifie que les bars les
restaurants les salles de sports
devraient fermer leurs portes avec un
soutien économique qui serait prévu la
nouveauté concernant les dérogations les
autorisations de sortie serait
l'accompagnement des enfants à l'école
un qui serait évidemment évidemment
accepté les mesures de contrôles
sanitaires aux frontières seront
renforcées et puis voilà en tout cas on
se prépare donc un durcissement
confinement mais avec une activité
économique préserver voilà ce qu'on peut
dire pour le moment des premières
informations qui filtrent mais cela
reste bien entendu au conditionnel je le
répète
merci beaucoup katia pour toutes ces
précisions à katia technique en direct
depuis l elysée dans environ 30 secondes
maintenant le chef de l'état elle va
donc s'adresser aux français une prise
de parole je le disais deux semaines
après le début du couvre-feu dans les
métropoles françaises les plus touchées
mais l'heure est désormais aux mesures
radical et on va les connaître dans
environ environ 15 secondes
maintenant les chiffres de la maladie en
france sont en constante dégradation
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines nombre de
cas confirmés a dépassé le million et le
taux de positivité des tests pcr qui
était de 13,7 pour cent en écoute tout
de suite
le président de la république priorité
au direct sur référence
[Musique]
françaises français mes chers
compatriotes
la dernière fois que je me suis adressé
à vous au sujet de la pandémie qui nous
frappe
j'avais fixé un délai une dizaine de
jours pour juger de l'efficacité des
choix faits et décider de l'opportunité
de mesures nouvelles
nous y sommes et si les efforts
consentis ont été utiles la lucidité
commandes admettre que cela ne suffit
pas cela ne suffit plus alors qu'elle
est à cette heure la situation de notre
épidémie le virus circule en france à
une vitesse que même les prévisions les
plus pessimistes n'avait pas anticipé le
nombre de contaminations rapporté à la
population a doublé en moins de deux
semaines
hier 527 de nos compatriotes sont
décédés du cockpit 19
hier nous avons dénombré près de 3000
personnes en réanimation
soit plus de la moitié des capacités
nationales à la différence de la
première vague l'ensemble des régions se
trouve aujourd'hui au seuil d alerte
dans de nombreux endroits pour prendre
en charge les patients qu'ovide 19 nous
avons commencé à des programmes et des
opérations du coeur ou du cancer parfois
les mêmes qui avait dû être décalée au
printemps nous avons pris des mesures
elle était déjà difficile et je sais
qu'elles ont été perçues comme telles
par beaucoup d'entre vous elle est est
indispensable et elles ont souvent été
contestée parce qu'elle ne faisait pas
plaisir
elle se révèle toutefois insuffisantes
pour endiguer une vague qui aujourd'hui
touchent toute l'europe
notre stratégie a été définie dès l'été
c'était de vivre avec le virus et il
s'agissait de maîtriser sa circulation
en nous appuyant sur nos capacités pour
tester alerté protégés sur les gestes
barrières sur la protection des plus
fragiles et des mesures de
ralentissement de l'épidémie
territorialisée au plus près du terrain
c'est ce que nous avons fait depuis le
mois d'août avons-nous tout bien fait
non et je les dis il ya quinze jours on
peut toujours s'améliorer mais nous
avons fait tout notre possible et je
crois profondément que notre stratégie
était compte tenu des informations qui
étaient les nôtres la bonne
le fut d'ailleurs celle de tous les pays
européens nous aurions pu aller plus
vite au début sur les tests mais depuis
plusieurs semaines nous sommes un des
pays d'europe qui testent le plus nous
aurions collectivement sans doute dû
davantage respecté les gestes barrière
en particulier au sein de la famille ou
avec les amis qui sont les lieux où nous
sommes le plus contaminé
faut-il nous le reprocher maintenant
mais surtout il faut reconnaître que
comme tous nos voisins nous sommes
submergés par l'accélération soudaine de
l'épidémie par un virus qui semble
gagner en force à mesure que l'hiver
approche que les températures baissent
une fois encore il faut avoir beaucoup
d'humilité nous sommes tous en europe
surpris par l'évolution du virus
certains pays comme l'espagne l'irlande
les pays bas ont pris plus tôt des
mesures plus dures que les nôtres
pourtant tous nous en sommes au même
point
débordé par une deuxième vague qui nous
le savons désormais sera sans doute plus
dur et plus meurtrière que la première à
ce stade nous savons que quoi que nous
fassions près de 9000 patients seront en
réanimation à la mi-novembre soit la
quasi totalité des capacités françaises
nous nous organisons nous organisons
bien sûr pour y faire face
rouvrir des lits supplémentaires et nous
allons faire le maximum d'efforts tous
ensemble mais ce n'est pas suffisant si
nous ne donnons pas aujourd'hui un coup
de frein brutal aux contaminations nos
hôpitaux seront très vite saturés sans
que nous ayons cette fois la possibilité
de transférer beaucoup de patients d'une
région à une autre parce que le virus
est partout si nous ne donnons pas
aujourd'hui un coup de frein brutal aux
contaminations
les médecins devront alors choisir ici
entre un patient atteint du code vie d
une personne victime d'un accident de la
route
là entre deux malades du cobp id
ce qui compte tenu des valeurs qui sont
les nôtres de ce qu'est la france de ce
que nous sommes et inacceptable
dans ce contexte ma responsabilité est
de protéger tous les français et en
dépit des polémiques en dépit de la
difficulté des décisions à prendre
je les assume pleinement devant vous ce
soir
quelles sont nos objectifs d'abord c'est
le premier protéger les plus âgés les
plus fragiles celles et ceux qui sont
atteints de diabète d'obésité
d'hypertension de maladies chroniques et
qui sont les premières victimes
une copie de 19 l'âge est le facteur
prépondérant 85 % des malades décédés
ont plus de 70 ans
notre deuxième objectif c'est de
protéger les plus jeunes je l' ai déjà
dit si le virus tue les plus âgés ils
tuent aussi même si c'est rare les plus
jeunes
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
35% des personnes en réanimation ou
moins de 65 ans il touche donc sous des
formes graves
toutes les générations et nous ne savons
pas dire aujourd'hui quelles sont les
séquelles à long terme perte d'odorat
perte de goût difficultés respiratoires
contracté ce virus n'est jamais anodin
même lorsqu'on a 20 ans troisième
objectif est de protéger nos soignants
qui à l'hôpital dans les structures
médico sociales en ville ont déjà
beaucoup donné durant le printemps
ils ont ensuite dû redoubler d'activité
durant l'été pour rattraper les acteurs
reporté au printemps
et malgré la fatigue ils font face
aujourd'hui à cette montée soudaine des
urgences nous leur devons de prendre
toutes les précautions pour limiter la
propagation du virus
si nous ne le faisons pas pour nous pour
nos proches faisons le pour eux il
s'agit troisièmement de protéger les
plus modestes qui parce qu'ils vivent
dans des lieux plus exigus parce qu'ils
occupent des emplois précaires sont les
plus touchés par le virus
sur le plan sanitaire mais ce sont aussi
les plus touchés par les conséquences
économiques et sociales de la crise
enfin il nous faut protéger notre
économie
je ne crois pas à l'opposition entre
santé économique certains voudraient
instaurer
il n'y a pas d'économie prospère dans
une situation sanitaire dégradées avec
un virus qui circule activement et je
vous le dis très clairement il n'y a pas
non plus un système de santé qui tient
s'il n'y a pas une économie forte pour
le financer c'est donc un juste
équilibre qu'il nous faut sans cesse
rechercher sans jamais perdre de vue un
principe intangible
pour nous rien n'est plus important que
la vie humaine qu'elles sont dès lors
les stratégies possibles pour arriver à
ses objectifs nous pourrions certains
préconisent ne rien faire et assumée de
laisser le virus circule et c'est ce
qu'on appelle la recherche de l'immunité
collective
c'est à dire lorsque 50 60 % de la
population a été contaminé le conseil
scientifique à évaluer les conséquences
d'une telle option elles sont
implacables à très court terme cela
signifie le tri entre les patients à
l'hôpital
et d'ici quelques mois c'est au moins
quatre cent mille morts supplémentaires
à déplorer jamais la france n'a doctorat
cette stratégie
jamais nous ne laisserons mourir des
centaines de milliers de nos concitoyens
ce ne sont pas nos valeurs ça n'est pas
non plus notre intérêt une deuxième voie
serait de confiner les seules personnes
à risque cette voie n'est pas non plus
au moment
d'abord elle suppose une discussion
éthiques mais d'une part nos aînés comme
les personnes vulnérables souvent besoin
d'une assistance extérieure pour leurs
soins leur ménage la livraison de leurs
repas certains vivent aussi avec leurs
proches leurs enfants souvent par manque
de moyens et donc créer une forme de
bulle autour d'une génération de
certaines personnes comme une barrière
entre les générations n'est pas réaliste
et à ce stade insuffisant d'autre part
le virus se développe aussi et
développent des formes graves chez les
plus jeunes et donc confiné les seules
personnes âgées est inefficace parce que
le virus circule ray toujours trop vite
c'est sous des formes graves dans le
reste de la population et donc nous ne
pourrions pas protéger nos soignants nos
urgences et même à terme nos aînés avec
cette stratégie
elle peut être pertinente elle n'est pas
suffisante nous pourrions également
faire en quelque sorte le pari de tout
miser sur la stratégie du tester alerte
et protégés après tout nous réalisons
1,9 million de tests par semaine nous
sommes l'un des meilleurs pays d'europe
aujourd'hui en la matière et grâce au
travail remarquable de l'assurance
maladie des agences régionales de santé
cent mille appels sont passées chaque
jour pour identifier les cas contacts et
briser les chaînes de contamination mais
si ce système peut être efficace avec
quelques milliers de cas par jour
nous avons aujourd'hui entre 40 et 50
mille contamination quotidienne des
pistes et sans doute en réalité le
double ce système mais plus efficace et
d'ailleurs aucun pays européen ne le
retient plus aujourd'hui
quant à la piste de l'augmentation de
nos capacités de réanimation que
certains évoquent comme une piste qui
nous permettraient de ne pas prendre des
mesures difficiles aujourd'hui je vais
vous dire très clairement nous sommes en
train de le faire mais là non plus ce
n'est pas une bonne réponse nous avons
les stocks de médicaments les
respirateurs les masques les blues les
gants tout le matériel nécessaire parce
que nous avons appris de nos
insuffisances de nos manques
durant la première phase nous avons
aussi formé près de 7000 7000 infirmiers
et médecins pour pouvoir travailler en
réanimation et nous avons ainsi pousser
nos capacités qui sont passés de 5000
lits avant la première vague assimile
aujourd'hui et nous allons les porter au
delà de dix mille lits en réanimation
donc un effort colossal a été fait de
formation d'investissement mais il n'est
pas suffisant face à cette vague
nous agissons aussi sur le moyen terme
le ségur de la santé qui correspond à 8
milliards d'investissements par an
investi dans l'hôpital et notre santé
permettra de renforcer l'attractivité
des métiers mais il faut cinq ans pour
former un affirmé réanimateurs dix ans
pour former un anesthésiste du reste
quand bien même nous pourrions ouvrir
beaucoup plus de lits et malgré l'effort
de doublement nous avons réussi qui peut
sérieusement vouloir que des milliers de
nos compatriotes
autre passe des semaines en réanimation
avec les séquelles que cela implique sur
le plan médical quel est donc
aujourd'hui la bonne stratégie à retenir
confiner les plus âgées les plus
vulnérables tester alerte et protégé
augmenter les lits de réanimation
aucune de ces solutions est suffisante
en l'état actuel il faut aller plus loin
après avoir consulté les scientifiques
dialoguer avec les forces politiques
économiques et sociales après avoir
échangé aussi avec tous nos partenaires
européens et peser le pour et le contre
j'ai décidé qu'il fallait retrouver à
partir de vendredi
le confinement qui a stoppé le virus
tout le territoire national est concerné
avec des adaptations pour les seuls
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
mais parce que nous avons appris des
événements du printemps ce confinement
sera adapté sur trois points principaux
les écoles resteront ouvertes le travail
pourra continuer les ehpad et les
maisons de retraite pourront être
visités quelles seront les règles de
cette nouvelle étape et le gouvernement
demain les détaillera lors d'une
conférence de presse
il ya d'abord ce qui ne changera pas par
rapport à ce que nous avons vécu au
printemps comme au printemps vous
pourrez sortir de chez vous uniquement
pour travailler vous rendre à un rendez
vous médical pour porter assistance à un
proche pour faire vos courses
essentielles ou prendre l'air à
proximité de votre domicile
c'est donc le retour de l'attestation
comme au printemps les réunions privées
en dehors du strict noyau familial
seront donc exclus les rassemblements
publics seront interdits et vous ne
pourrez pas vous déplacer d'une région à
l'autre à l'exception des retours de
vacances de la toussaint et donc il y
aura une tolérance
durant ce week-end de roquettes 10000
euros par mois de leurs pertes en
chiffre d'affaires les salariés et les
employeurs qui ne peuvent pas travailler
continueront quant à eux à bénéficier du
chômage partiel et nous compléterons par
des mesures de trésorerie pour les
charges
les loyers des prochaines semaines et un
plan spécial sera fait pour les
indépendants les commerçants
les très petites et moyennes entreprises
qui je le sais redoutent plus que tout
les prochaines semaines par rapport à
mars avril
nous avons je le disais à prix nous
avons progressé c'est pourquoi certaines
règles vont évoluer
d'abord nos enfants ne saurait être
durablement privé d'instruction
d'éducation de contact avec le système
scolaire trop de conséquences trop de
dégâts en particulier pour les plus
modestes
les crèches les écoles les collèges et
les lycées demeureront donc ouvert avec
des protocoles sanitaires renforcés les
facultés et établissement d'enseignement
supérieur assureront al'inverse des
cours en ligne partout c'est possible le
télétravail sera à nouveau
généraliser mais et c'est une seconde
différence par rapport au printemps
l'activité continuera avec plus
d'intensité
ce qui veut dire que les guichets des
services publics resteront ouverts les
usines les exploitations agricoles les
bâtiments et travaux publics
continueront de fonctionner l'économie
ne doit ni s'arrêter ni s'effondrer je
vous invite donc bilité de chacun à
participer de cet effort en travaillant
en soutenant les entreprises aussi qui
proche de chez vous ont innové à travers
des commandes à distance la vente à
emporter ou la livraison à domicile
le gouvernement d'ailleurs accompagnera
les très petites et petites entreprises
comme les moyennes entreprises ont aussi
qu'ils entreprendront des démarches de
numérisation nos frontières intérieures
à l'espace européen demeureront ouvertes
et sauf exception les frontières
extérieures resteront fermés
bien évidemment les français de
l'étranger resteront libres de regagner
le territoire dans les ports les
aéroports pour les déplacements
internationaux des tests rapides
obligatoires seront déployés pour toutes
les arrivées aucun voyageur ne doit
pouvoir entrer sur le territoire
européen sans qu'on soit certain qu'il
n'est pas ce fait des règles sanitaires
je souhaite aussi que les personnes en
situation de handicap puissent
bénéficier des souplesses dont elles ont
besoin
quant au cimetière en cette période
marquée par la toussaint ils demeureront
ouverts
je veux que nous puissions continuer à
enterrer dignement nos proches
ce nouveau confinement ne réussira que
par la mobilisation de tous et chacun a
son rôle à jouer aux personnes à risque
aux plus vulnérables aux personnes âgées
de plus de 70 ans je demande une
vigilance accrue moins de réunions avec
la famille avec les amis même si c'est
un crève coeur et le respect de la
distanciation physique y compris au
domicile le port du masque systématique
lorsqu'on se trouve à l'intérieur en
présence d'une autre personne même un
proche même un enfant ou un petit enfant
c'est très important pour vous les
soignants à l'hôpital joue évidemment
dans ce contexte un rôle essentiel mais
nous avons besoin des médecins de ville
des infirmiers des pharmaciens de tous
les acteurs du médico social de tous les
professionnels de santé de ville pour
assurer une prise en charge précoce des
patients dès les premiers symptômes
et pour éviter que ne se développent des
formes complexes nous avons besoin de
nos élus nos mères ont joué un rôle
essentiel est gelée celui-ci maires
présidents et présidentes
d'intercommunalité de métropole élus de
terrain nous allons avoir besoin de vous
de manière encore accrue pour proposer
et aller plus loin en matière de
prévention mobiliser nos associations
pour accompagner les personnes les plus
isolées les moins bien informés et
assuré la bonne application des mesures
prises que ce soit auprès de nos jeunes
dans le temps périscolaire ou pour
accompagner les personnes les plus
vulnérables les plus âgés nous avons
besoin de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure pour garantir l'application
des mesures de nos forces de sécurité
civile pour déployer des plateformes de
test est allé au contact de la
population
nous avons aussi besoin du sens des
responsabilités de chacun et de l'esprit
citoyen de tous rester au maximum chez
vous respectez les règles
une fois encore je vous le dis la
réussite dépend du stand redit et elles
seront appliquées à minima jusqu'au 1er
décembre dès demain un débat suivi d'un
vote se tiendra au parlement
dès demain le gouvernement détaillera
toutes ces mesures nous devons nous
honorer de cette transparence et du fait
que des décisions difficiles se fasse
dans un cadre démocratique où toutes les
oppositions peuvent s'exprimer dès
demain également je participerai un
conseil européen pour coordonner les
réponses sanitaires des différents pays
de l'union
tous les quinze jours nous ferons le
point sur l'évolution de l'épidémie nous
déciderons le cas échéant de mesures
complémentaires et nous évaluerons alors
si nous pouvons aller j'ai certaines
contraintes en particulier sur les
commerces
je sais que beaucoup de commerçants
espérer ne pas fermer
je sais que pour les commerces de centre
ville je demande un très gros effort
tenons le avec beaucoup de rigueur
pendant quinze jours
si d'ici 15 jours nous maîtrisons mieux
la situation nous pourrons alors révélé
les choses et espérer ouvrir certains
commerces en particulier dans cette
période si importante avant les fêtes de
noël
nous verrons si nous pouvons cultiver
l'espoir de célébrer en famille ce
moment si précieux de noël et des fêtes
de fin d'année notre objectif à terme
est simple réduire très fortement les
contaminations est passé de 40 mille
contamination par jour à 5000 ralentir
significativement le rythme des entrées
à l'hôpital est en réanimation et ce
n'est qu'alors que nous pourrons
pleinement redéployer une stratégie
tester alerte et protégé redéployer
beaucoup plus massivement l'application
tout senti qu vide qui sera un
instrument de la sortie de cette phase
de confinement test en 30 minutes
meyer traçage isolement plus efficace
des personnes positives qui est un sujet
sur lequel nous devons continuer à
réfléchir une fois le pic épidémique
passé tous ces outils doivent nous
permettre demain de tenir jusqu'aux
vaccin à l'été nous disent les
scientifiques
mes chers compatriotes nous avons tous
été surpris par l'accélération soudaine
de l'epide qu'elle éprouve justement
notre résilience et notre unité
mais elle est un révélateur de ce que
nous sommes des femmes et des hommes qui
sont liés les uns aux autres très peu de
générations auront eu comme la nôtre
autant de défis ensemble cette pandémie
historique les crises internationales le
terrorisme les divisions de la société
et une crise économique et sociale sans
précédent liée à la première vague mais
j'ai confiance en nous en vous confiance
en notre capacité à surmonter cette
épreuve
nous devons tenir chacun à notre place
dans la transparence le débat dans la
détermination pour appliquer les règles
que nous nous fixons et en nous serrant
les coudes à nouveau nous nous
relèverons
si nous sommes unis et nous serons unis
nous avons besoin les uns des autres
nous sommes une nation unie et solidaire
et c'est à cette condition que nous y
arriverons nous sommes la france
je compte sur chacun d'entre vous je
serai là nous serons là et nous y
arriverons
tous ensemble vive la république et vive
la france